bienvenue à tous vous êtes sur envergure
le podcast site internet aussi
spécialiste du scooting basketball et
avec ce podcast en inaugure notre série
de portraits pour la draft 2023 on prend
les candidats un par un les jeunes et on
vous donne l'essentiel donc voici pour
ce premier numéro l'essentiel sur caméra
[Musique]
wit more vous pouvez l'appeler camit
more née le 8 juillet 2004 donc il aura
encore 18 ans le soir de la draft à ces
jeunes il aura 19 ans peu de temps après
il est au niveau des mobdraft chez nos
amis di espienne 7e quatrième chez CBS
et chez nous carrément troisième vous
pouvez aller voir notre notre big board
sur le site il est plutôt monté cette
saison je vous donne le contexte c'est
un ailier qui est qui est plutôt monté
petit à petit depuis l'année dernière en
fait sur sur les mobs graphes les big
board depuis sa performance avec
l'équipe nationale américaine lors du
tournoi continental puisqu'il a été élu
à MVP à remporté le FIBA U18 et il a
profité des flashs cette saison à
Vilanova puisque c'est un joueur de
Vilanova cette saison pour pour
grappiller quelques places dans les
bornes
pour en parler nous avons Julien nous
avons Hugues
bonjour bonsoir à tous salut
dans ces podcasts on va toujours
commencer par une biographie pour
l'essentiel sur Camut more il faut
savoir d'abord d'où il vient ce qu'il a
des parents célèbre et ce qu'il a une
coupe de cheveux particulière
Julien c'est à toi
alors il a une coupe de cheveux
particulière il est originaire du mari
land une petite ville en concentre le
Baltimore et Washington
lycée dans le bar et landossy dans sa
bio dans son arbre généalogique on peut
trouver un cousin basketteur
mais c'était en 66 donc ça commence à
remonter sinon
c'est un gars qui est suivi depuis
longtemps il a il a fait tous les
McDonald's
[Musique]
Jordan Brown classique a eu on l'a vu et
comme tu disais
gros
flash lors du 18 à Tijuana est-ce qu'on
conseille d'aller voir les matchs
si si on veut voir des bodins quoi
cette année donc à Vilanova avec le
coach Kyle Neptune magnifique non
incroyable
Frishman of the Year dans la biggiste et
donc et donc candidat à cette draft NBA
2023 Hugues à Vilanova comment était-il
utilisé qu'il y avait autour de lui quel
rôle il avait ce joueur on parle de son
année NCA ouais on va c'est pas la
partie la plus réjouissante c'est une
année compliquée avia Nova pour lui et
pour Villa Nova changement de coach
après le départ du mythique jewite
qu'elle Neptune donc Sailor Moon
apparemment qui prend le relais et
kamotement en plus il commence à se
blesser il a il joue pas les premiers
matchs alors lui il est blessé il
revient d'une blessure au et leur leader
Justin Moore qui était candidat la draft
l'an dernier avant de se faire les
croiser lui aussi n'est pas là en début
de saison donc vraiment c'est c'est une
équipe un peu en perdition d'ailleurs
avec beaucoup beaucoup de défaites dans
ce marasme là il a essayé de montrer
quelque chose dont on attendait pas
forcément c'était de montrer qu'il était
capable de se créer son propre tiens
notamment au tir extérieur on
connaissait la bruit de physique qu'il
était où il a vraiment sûr de miner le
tournoi des Amériques comme tu comme ça
a été dit il a pris énormément de tirs à
trois points c'est le secteur
majoritaire de son de son jeu en début
de saison après c'est un peu rapproché
du panier 33 points d'efficacité la
moitié en pull-up donc il a essayé
vraiment de montrer step back de montrer
un peu de cross de montrer je mets du
contact et je recule une efficacité
quand même très très relative et par
contre près du cercle quand il était
dans du cut quand il était sur de la
transition parce que c'est son son point
fort nous développera un peu après
lorsqu'il peut vraiment se projeter vers
l'avant et et montrer l'étendue de sa
brutalité vu qu'il est fan de Russell
Westbrook on retrouve ça là dedans 66%
près du panier 72 % lancés francs white
assez bas quand même et puis sur le sur
le poulpe encore une fois il laisse
montrer quelque chose qui n'était pas
particulièrement beaucoup de beaucoup de
tirs très compliqués à mi distance avec
du fait etc du jeu un peu postaux
post-bage mes cartes et je tire un peu
un peu Dulux Rhône de l'ESK pour parler
à notre fan des Nyx qui est Julien ici
et 27% d'efficacité donc vraiment
résistance pas terrible pas fou est-ce
que il était puni pour ça est-ce que
Kyle est-ce qu'on laissait faire un peu
ce qu'il voulait
et défensivement c'était quoi son
contexte on le mettait plus sur des gros
joueurs adverses
en fait du la Nova est tellement en
galère offensive que on l'a laissé
prendre pas mal de jeux à son compte
c'est comme le troisième volume de tir
de l'équipe alors qui joue pas en début
on alternat pas de c'est une équipe
dédiée j'ai à Nova qui a que ça en gros
c'est très NBA mais sans gagner des
matchs on a plein de mecs de 2 m Éric
Dixon le pivot qui fait genre de mètres
0,3 Brandon slator on était fan toi et
moi l'an dernier qui a de mettre aussi
donc on alterné et puis on voyait qui
pouvait mettre un panier c'était c'était
rarement rarement joli à voir et puis
défensivement bah il a pas il était
assez perdu
il a fait des petits prenait pas le
meilleur des fois le meilleur pourtant
de balader vers c'était la
responsabilité de Brandon Slater puis de
Justin Moore pour les pour les petits
extérieurs donc il était sur du second
rideau et puis on voyait quand même
qu'il y avait un retour de blessure pour
notre ami kamouit more ou il était pas
il était pas léger sur les appuis et il
a été pas mal en difficulté sur le
rencontrer
j'avais donner sa taille il me semble il
fait un mètre 99 pour 95 kg ça ce sont
les stats officiels sur sa page sur son
scooting report écrit par Manu sur
envergure.co quelle est sa quel est son
ticket d'entrée puisque ça va être la
question à chaque fois pour ces
essentiels sur les jeunes pour ses
podcasts sur les la prédraft 2023 jus
comment tu tu vois qu'est-ce qu'on
achète chez lui quand on le draft donc
potentiellement dans le top 10 si on
dans le top 10 si on croit les mobs
draft
c'est un jeune homme qui est
quoi de moi alors moi j'ai deux mètres
et plus de 100 kg
c'est des grosses épaules c'est un type
qui a qui a une explosivité une
puissance qui est assez incroyable donc
je pense que ça c'est c'est vraiment ce
qui marque les esprits avec lui et avec
ça du coup
bah quand il est lancé c'est un driver
impressionnant il a des appuis notamment
un dernier appui qui lui permet de de
scorer ou de provoquer des fautes
et
puis c'est des promesses aussi au niveau
de la défense je pense quoi pour pour
impacter de manière générale donc moi je
dirais ça puissance et
et puis les promesses de
scoring qui est en train de développer
Hugues est-ce que tu as des choses à
ajouter si toi tu le draft est-ce que
pour quelle raison tu le fais
effectivement en avance en avance
physiquement alors qu'il a 18 ans encore
ça compte les jeunes équipes souvent
très vite régulièrement parce que elles
sont pas très bonnes donc elles étaient
accéléré lui sur up tempo il va être
létal vraiment dans de la course il
montre qu'il est capable de changer de
changer de vitesse changer de direction
assez brusquement sur ces secteurs là
très bonne adaptabilité en termes de
réflexe il voit une situation il arrive
très bien à lire là toujours la
transition et à terminer donc il y a en
fait il y a un plancher physique et une
potentialité qui font que ce sera très
excitant l'impression que l'information
va vite du cerveau muscles quoi ça
permet de réagir
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on doit
travailler maintenant parce que déjà eu
que vous avez une question pour toi tu
parlais du contexte on voit une brute
physique on voit un gars qui qui voilà
qui domine physiquement par rapport à la
moyenne NCIS même si dans une bonne
conférence
25% de fuite forright tu le disais ça
c'est un peu faible ça veut dire en gros
qui tente un lancer franc pour quatre
tirs tentés je traduis
pour ceux qui nous écoutent c'est pas
beaucoup normalement les joueurs
physiquement dominants ils vont être au
moins au-delà de 30-35 quoi
pourquoi
parce que je pense qu'il a vraiment
essayé de comme je te le disais avant de
montrer qu'il pouvait écarter son jeu il
a comment dire il a voulu trop en faire
il a voulu se survendre et il a voulu
montrer qu'il pouvait désaxer au niveau
de la finition près du panier il a voulu
qu'il pouvait
repasser sur du poste bas et fait de
derrière donc voilà il a tendance à
vouloir faire trop vite et du coup à
perdre son équilibre alors il réagit
très vite mais lorsqu'il a décidé de
faire quelque chose de base bah il a du
mal à tu vois il veut vraiment faire ça
pour l'instant il est il y est pas
encore
et puis il a
comme il y avait peu de mouvement et
qu'il y avait peu de transition avec
Vilanova c'est une équipe qui jouait pas
non plus très rapidement il a dû
beaucoup sur dribbler et quand il
surdribble quand il va organiser il a il
perd son dribble il a pas encore le
handle nécessaire
non et non clairement pas clairement pas
et il prend pas les bonnes décisions à
ce moment-là donc on voit tu vois il
pose 3 4 5 6 7 8 ça arrêtera jamais
finalement il transfère ballon à
l'opposé parce que parce que c'est
stérile comme si situation donc on est
vraiment sur un joueur très très brut et
je pense que le contexte est-ce que lui
voulait faire c'était pas c'était pas en
accord avec ce qu'il est pour le moment
qu'est-ce qu'on doit travailler jus pour
pour ses premières cesser ses premières
années pour pouvoir le développer
qu'est-ce qui lui manque qu'est-ce qui
pourrait lui manquer au-delà de la
maturité
je pense une régularité aux shoot
alors
ce que j'ai cette année j'ai
l'impression j'ai l'impression qu'il a
progressé alors il en a pris beaucoup
j'ai l'impression qu'il a progressé dans
la
dans la confiance qu'il a dans son shoot
et dans les moments où il les prend je
sais pas ce que tu en penses Hugues mais
moi je l'ai vu progresser là dedans
durant l'année alors il était blessé au
début donc peut-être que ça
refuse cette impression et
par rapport à la réactivité moi je
trouve que il manque quelque chose au
niveau de la défense par rapport à ça il
est souvent pris de vitesse par les les
attaquants qui doivent surveiller et
puis il prend beaucoup de shoot sur sur
la tête quoi à chaque match on le voit
prendre il prend deux ou trois
points sur la tête alors qu'il est collé
au gars quoi
donc je alors il devrait avoir il
devrait pas laisser passer ce genre de
truc et pourtant il est il en prend
quelques-uns
on passe à la partie suivante et on va
parler du rôle rôle en année un rôle en
année 3 4 c'est à dire fin de contrat
ruquis comment tu vois
le rôle qui pourrait avoir demain dans
une équipe bon plutôt du bas de tableau
on imagine puisque s'il est drafté dans
le top 10 ce sera le cas
je pense qu'il va vraiment être cette
énergie brutasse qui va en gros attaquer
forceur transition qui va prendre du tir
à trois points on va le laisser prendre
du tir à trois points
qui va avoir des attentes défensive et
je pense qu'il va élever son niveau
défensif
je j'ai envie de mettre le contexte
Vilanova et ce début où il est perdu
pas de côté mais voilà je vais je vais
un peu le comment dire être indulgent
là-dessus et dans son développement
vraiment ça va être sur
le dribble une équipe qui va le payer si
haut va vouloir qu'il puisse créer son
propre tir à minima pour lui et ensuite
créer collectivement dans un second
temps je pense que le tous les ans on a
un mais le le développement parfait pour
lui ce qui doit être visé c'est dialon
Brown c'est vraiment et tous les ans on
a on a le jalon Brown on l'avait fait
pour Isa Cocoro qui pour l'instant
on le cherche tout le temps il y a quand
même peut-être plus de stabilité au
niveau du tir pour pour ce jeune garçon
que kizakokoro à la même époque et
voilà oui parce que 34% à 3 points avec
seulement 50% qui vient d'une passe
décisive c'est pas mal
en fait moi ce qui me gêne plus pour pas
être vulgaire c'est vraiment qui il
arrive pas à ne tirer sans poser la
balle au sol quoi il est obligé tu vois
de de poser un de dribble entre les
jambes et ensuite de déclencher alors
qu'il est très efficace oui il a plus de
50% lorsqu'il pose pas la balle juste il
fait du catch and shoot pur et il y a
une mode c'est marrant parce qu'il y a
absolument tout ce que vous dites depuis
tout à l'heure mais vraiment 100% des
trucs ça marche Anthony Edwards
absolument tout quoi et donc Anthony
Edwards a réussi parce qu'il est draftéo
donc lui a donné la balle et aussi parce
que c'est un
uber athlète c'est peut-être un des 5
meilleurs athlètes drafté sur les 10
dernières années
c'est même très certainement
donc est-ce qu'il est à ce niveau là et
que vous en pensez de cette ce d'accord
ce serait un peu le meilleur scénario
fondamentaux je pense tu sais dans le
dans le job step dans le côté un peu on
disait genre Mello des arrières tu vois
Joe Johnson etc il y avait plus de de
comment dire
d'appui tout ça ouais vraiment dans le
départ il était il était létal là-dessus
tu sais pas dans quel chant il pouvait
aller par exemple on en a pas parlé mais
qu'un mit Morse c'est un mec ambidextre
qui tire de la main droite mais qui
drève quasiment que la main gauche tu
vois et donc déjà là-dessus il y a une
sorte d'assymétrie c'est que il adore
partir à gauche et sa préférence motrice
alors partir à gauche mais il est obligé
de terminer avec la droite et c'est pas
dans des situations vraiment très
compliquées et donc je pense qu'il y a
un vrai travail d'habitude motrice de
correction de est-ce que les staff NBA
vont très bien savoir faire et de voilà
de de mise en valeur pour optimiser
l'athlète et le et le joueur qu'il juge
est-ce que tu as un scénario médian du
coup pour son rôle qui pourrait avoir
faire la fin de son contrat Rocky 3 4
ans
un truc réaliste réaliste envisageable
et quand même assez positif
tu veux il faut que forcément une
comparer pas forcément un nom mais tu
vois dans le dans ce qui dans ce qui
quel rôle il pourra avoir tu vois ce qui
serait vraiment dans les joueurs
importants d'une équipe et ce qui serait
le
Andrew Wiggins d'une équipe de de
playoff tu vois mais c'est tout ce qu'on
lui souhaite et puis
on en avait parlé avec Thomas et Manu le
dit dans son soutien de porte il y a des
promesses aussi à la passe et peut-être
qu'il faut en parler à des pas forcément
dans la création pure du jeu mais en
tant que connecteur ou relais il a ça
donc ça peut dû assurer un rôle plus
important que juste
comment dire un gars qui a de la
puissance et qui va qui va trouver son
chemin en panier quoi donc
ça voilà je l'ouvre en scénario médian
ça peut être ça ok ok
alors c'est pas forcément hyper sexy
comme ça mais ce que je pense qui est
important aussi c'est que à la future
draft quasiment toutes les équipes là du
top 7 8 quand on parle pour lui ont des
forts porteurs de balles créateurs et
donc déjà on va le ça va le décharger de
quelque chose et il va pouvoir être sur
un rôle de finisseur puissant et ensuite
développer ce skills handball donc
je vais prendre mon temps exactement
donc je pense que ça vraiment il y a
beaucoup de très bonnes situations pour
lui pour ne pas ne pas parodier Astérix
mission Cléopâtre mais je crois vraiment
que il y a beaucoup d'équipes qui
peuvent offrir un très très beau
développement
à notre ami Kamo hitmore et pour que ça
fonctionne
et donc alors juste avant de de terminer
sur
à chaque fois on va terminer c'est ces
podcasts ces essentiels sur est-ce qu'on
y croit est-ce qu'on n'y croit pas un
mot de la psychologie quand même du
joueur qu'est-ce que vous en vous en
avez vu si vous en avez vu quelque chose
si on parle à la fois de body language
on parle à la fois de déclaration de
comportement hors terrain etc
moi j'aime bien ce qui dégage quoi
j'aime bien ce qui dégage sur un terrain
l'assurance qu'il a le comment dire le
contrôle dans les moments où il va il va
prendre des choses ou essayer de se
correr et puis des moments où il va plus
être au service du collectif et je
trouve c'est un joueur spécial quoi à
regarder donc moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas
lui d'interview de lui mais en tout cas
sur le terrain je trouve qu'il dégage
quelque chose
il y a certains de ces coachs j'avais
pas mal de ses coachs qui ont dit que
c'est un jeune garçon qui aimait son
sport tu parlais de tout à l'heure il y
avait ces déclarations là juste avant la
draft on avait un peu stressé il disait
moi j'aime pas trop le basket et je
regarde pas ce qui est le cas de
beaucoup de gens pas de basket mais lui
beaucoup de gens lui disent voilà il
aime il aime ça il aime son jeu il est
très souvent le premier à relever ses
coéquipiers à les féliciter c'est un mec
qui est à la fois très agressif et qui
est très calme il peut exploser mais
quand il rate ou quand il fait des
erreurs etc il va pas il va pas trop se
frustrer donc
les signaux ont l'air assez haut vers là
dessus un point de vue extérieur d'un
œil extérieur
et le fait de faire les sélections
jeunes Américaines et toujours un point
positif quasiment toujours en tout cas
ça veut dire que tu peux te fondre dans
un collectif et lui en l'occurrence il
fait MVP même si c'est d'une compétition
dominée de la tête et des épaules
jus est-ce que tu crois en camouite mort
est-ce que tu crois qui vaudra son choix
de draft parce que il croit bon je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord pour dire que il
a un potentiel pour devenir pro et ce
qu'il vaudra son top 7 8
je pense qu'il a trouvé son chemin je
pense qu'il va trouver son chemin il a
trop d'atouts en main en épaule en
tout ce que tu veux pour
et puis il y a cette mentalité il y a
des il y a trop de promesses à beaucoup
de niveaux pour que pour qu'il se plante
tout à l'heure tu réaffirmes
ouais je l'aime bien donc en plus c'est
un bien mais j'y crois je pense qu'il y
aura des mecs qui seront ratés après lui
qui ont peut-être un rôle plus important
et qui ont une carrière plus flashy
parce qu'ils seront meilleurs porteurs
de balles et je pense qu'il y a des mecs
qui seront rachetés avant lui qui feront
une bonne carrière donc à la fin on se
retrouvera
mais il y a pas c'est pas pour finir là
dessus on n'est pas sur
un si gros risque que ça même si c'est
un joueur ou alors le risque ce serait
de ne pas le faire jouer du tout quoi
mais c'est quand on parle de risquer
Ward le rapport c'est le rapport qualité
prix
transposé à la draft quoi c'est à dire à
quel point à quel point c'est risqué de
drafter ce joueur même s'il est jeune on
a des qualités physiques qui sont une
assurance pour pour l'avenir et donc ce
shoot je pense que c'est aussi ça qu'il
a voulu cette année je sais pas ce que
tu en penses-tu mais
c'est ce qu'on lui disait en tout cas
l'année dernière on disait c'est un
super athlète mais il sait pas shooté ça
va être dur pour la NBA bon là il a
voulu montrer qu'il savait shooter
je ne suis pas qu'une bruit de physique
je ne suis pas kizakokoro qui est drive
tes 4e et oui c'est c'est le problème
c'est qu'ils ont dans une draft qui
s'annonce être une draft mais ce qui est
pas forcément un problème
non mais voilà tu vois quand tu es quand
tu vas faire la rhydrate et que tu as
des énormes joueurs tu te dis
bon ben peut-être qu'à mit more c'est
pas comme il va pas avoir autant de
ballons en main qu'à scooter Anderson
qu'un amène Thomson pour citer que
peut-être que tu te dis à la fin bah
ouais j'aurais peut-être pu avoir un
gars d'un talon All-Star super star et
j'ai pris Aaron Gordon si je veux te
désagréable
si vraiment voilà une excellente
carrière mais c'est ce genre de
réflexion là mais oui il y a moi je vois
pas un scénario où il a pas au moins 2e
voir un troisième contrat nbase j'ai une
belle réussite
alright j'ai eu un mot de la fin une
anecdote
engagé sur rien voilà c'était notre
notre premier format l'essentiel
d'avant draft donc pour la draft NBA
2023 l'essentiel de sur Cannes 8 morts
joueurs de Vilanova projeté dans le top
10 de cette draft NBA 2023 pour trouver
son scouting report écrit par Manu sur
envergure.co et vous retrouvez tout
plein de podcasts et des missions sur
les différentes plateformes Deezer
Spotify Google podcast également sur
Youtube et vous retrouver
aussi vous pouvez nous retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux puisque on se réactive à
l'approche de la draft on vous embrasse
Ciao